coming to the big screen Walt Disney
Pictures proudly presents gargoyles from
the studio that put Eddie Murphy in the
haunted mansion Keira Knightley as a
pirate and Mila Kunis as the Wicked
Witch we present another phenomenal miss
casting with Kanye West as Goliath yeah
I'm stoned by day and batshit crazy
monster by night also I'm apparently in
a movie because you love our film
versions of Cinderella and Beauty and
the Beast even though we already have
film versions of Cinderella and Beauty
and the Beast why do that shit we bring
you another misunderstanding of source
material by Cassie Ellen DeGeneres as
ELISA Massa bitch who the fuck are you
thing I'm your love interest say what
you clam chowder cracker don't worry
I've seen worse I dated Anne Heche
that's an old joke kids if you don't get
it ask your parents of course if you're
watching this you are your parents okay
not so fast with Kevin Costner as the
villainous XANA toes I am Xena toes
Santa tell I don't care I have sent on
my robotic army if you wish to save the
people you will have to fly up there and
stop them bitch that fuck I won't do any
fine let's have a crown of thorns or
halo what he supposed to do let all
those people die baby shit postman I can
buy you like my white AIIMS annexed oh
dammit oh I don't care I didn't watch
the show wings he writes letters over
fessor right yes they should be in his
left xamot oh it should really help
gargoyles
coming soon to a theatre dear hey let go
of me imma let you finish but I want you
to know that bonkers is one of the
greatest shows of all time and we
deserve a movie about a cartoon
character and a cock we have to we need
three hey you want to hear about the
show I'm producing that's gonna bomb
bitch don't make me chop you up and
smoke you I am Santa hos